wow it's ben feingold thanks ben
feingold
reading with 304 shout out to ben
man um i i feel like
i feel like a circus clown i'm juggling
so many things right now
i don't i don't even know how to juggle
shout out to
gm benjamin
feingold there we go
hi people if you're just joining i'm
i'm trying to to manage everything there
were a lot of questions
earlier that i probably didn't get to
there were gifted subs
but i think everything is under control
and let's play more chess
let's play i'll play a random sub
okay playing chess master one two one
oh dear i have to go blind now where's
my blindfold
okay i have to go blind is ben feingold
a random sub
you're a random mod
um but is anything truly random
okay i have to find my blindfold i'll be
right back
i found it it was chilling on the carpet
for some reason
anyway it's fine full time
good thing this is casual if you haven't
seen this before
uh it involves some speech
and some darkness
okay so chat has to behave yourself
yourselves if you don't behave yourself
then ben feingold
will put you in your place probably
at least one mod in the chat thanks for
the bit samsonite
okay let's do this goodbye to the visual
world e5
oh dear just like the best science
double blind
the best science what knight f6 okay
let's play a stafford gambit
the best oh like double
wait i'm confused
anyway oh my opponent is more confused
bishop c5
okay so we have a stafford gambit
basically just a petrov declined but i'm
still offering the pawn
i can take on e5 yeah if white wants to
okay knight c6 so stafford gambits
is being offered knight takes c6
yeah d takes c6
c3 oh okay so this is actually a cool
line
i had this recently against chessweeb
and i had this i think i actually had
this yesterday
um so i'm supposed to take on e4 knight
takes e4
oh no my knight eric if ben played 30
with 2002
and he spotted a queen what would his
result be what
short castle oh no my bishop
wait what something about ban and
spotting
bishop e3 opponents not taking anyone
any of my pieces that's so sad
bishop d6 bishop d3
wait ben spotted a queen
bishop d3
bishop d3
rook e8
knight d2 okay
there's a lot a lot of things happening
here
i i just wanna i wanna go for the kill
let's let's go attack queen h4 yeah
eric i spotted 2 200 a queen three
minutes
what's his result you're running 10
games also
your words don't make sense
i don't know what that meant you spotted
it
takes e4 something about ten games
okay rook takes e4 so all i wanted takes
e4
wait there's a bishop on d3
queen takes e4 oops
i don't even know my opponent's reading
queen f3
[Music]
uh
wait so i'm just down i'm down the
exchange but i have two bishops
of what else i'll play queen g6
queen g6 and keep the bishop here keep
the queens on the border
eric gave queen odds in three minute
licks to random 2
200 what would his result be in say 10
games
if he didn't watch g4 i didn't follow
that also
bishop e4 that's a skewer right
or a backwards pin
if he gave queen odds
i don't know he would probably win
everything right
queen e2
uh bishop h1 bishop takes h1 let's go
long castle oh that's legal i guess
that's legal
bishop ben wants to know how many games
you would win out of 10 if he
gave you queen odds oh if he gave me
queen
wait what does that mean f4
queen e6 whoever is missing the queen
would probably
just lose all the games right
i think unless there's some other odds
i'm not sure i really shouldn't be
thinking about that right now
just have to focus on winning
so the queen's on e2 i think not you
erica 2
200.
[Music]
there's my rook
okay so i'm up a bishop
but my queen's attacked my queen can
move
queen d6 okay the king's on d2
one minute 11 seconds black
one minute 19 seconds okay queen f2
still above a minute queen f2
play c5 c5 so i'm trying to break open
the center
f4 oh my queen's attacked again
queen d5
maybe between d5 don't hurt me
i think the pawns fell on c3 i better be
on c3
no one can silence beb fine gold boo
what boo hoo or boo
oh was that pen cheering if it's
vengeance then you can do what you
you want you don't have to be quiet
g5 oh
where did that move come from
okay let's i guess i can take
cd cd4 c takes d4
quindy for expected
queen takes d4 yeah um
i guess i'll trade queen queen takes d4
check
c takes d4 and then
wait where's my bishop
bishop f3 bishop f3
is rook f1 expected i i really gotta say
focus here this is not easy even though
i'm up a bishop
thanks for subbing by the way g1 from g1
there's a b4
b4 check check so the king's on d2
controlling e file
[Music]
[Music]
g6 what
h takes g6 is random f takes g6 what
oh it's maybe not so random
um f g6 f takes g6
king c4 a
5 rook takes g6
okay so b5 b5 check forcing the king
back to d3 and then i4
e4 check yeah let's go king e3
bishop takes g6 check king f3
bishop bishop e5
rook takes e5 d takes e5
bishop takes a2 h4
king f7 king e4
king e6 king d4
bishop takes b3 king e3
a 4 king e4
a 3 h5
a 2 h6
a one promotes to queen h7
queen h1 check king d4
queen takes age seven king e3
g5 kingdom
e2
oh i was trying to play queen h3 but
it's not legal
ah good thing that was casual
oh oh i was i had made one
too i just forgot where my bishops were
i knew i wanted to promote
oh that's so devastating oh
no oh
well i have a pawn too if i take the
pawn i can't lose
let's go boy let's go
[Music]
what to do i forgot the pawn was still
here man
oh ben's still here too so who was that
earlier
gg something about hey it's akd
thanks akd saying sorry about the slip
at the end
oh i played akd oh good game akd
well played audio was behind while both
were still moving pieces
yeah they fell back on time so
i there's an extension that kind of
stopped working
where you can change the the rate sorry
about the little slip at the end
oh no worries i'll forgive you someday
um as an interesting opening too
[Music]
oh thank you oh that was wait it's fen
being gold
oh yeah there's ben feingold and fen
being gold
and rookie mistakes gifting a sub so the
question is if ben gave queen odds to
random 2230 what would his result be
oh and 3-0 oh
um